celebrating your win is a satisfying
experience but some moments deserve
more than just the usual they deserve a pop off
it's a staple of esports nothing both feeds and
builds the height more than an incredible
pop off just make sure you've actually won
it though before you do it so smart he couldn't
burst because of the super but will she thinks
oh my god but before we get into that just
make sure you are subscribed to the channel
if you haven't done so already that way you'll
never miss any great videos just like this one
and with that let's get into the
top 10 pop-offs in esports history
kicking off our list is a pop-off from the
allegedly oldest man in the game i'm holding
[ __ ] with the worst gun in the game at the six
invitational 2020 space station gaming faced off
against tsm in the events group stage in a 1v3
situation canadian had to find some way out as
pulse wielding what is legitimately not a great
weapon canadian down below isolated he'll walk
right into geo and he wins the fight but he will
have to find the diffuser he doesn't have the
nitro cell available he will miss time it they'll
be able to get out of there very effectively
his retake from canadian will be tough bullo's
on only a tiny bit of hp down goes merc bullo's
one shot away we'll create it oh my god no
way he pulls that off and the defuser is his
afterwards canadian had some harsh words
for tsm as well as his former teammate geo
oh my god why am i so much better than you god
damn he's not [ __ ] humping you you [ __ ] little
[ __ ] still get your [ __ ] hang i'm holding
with the worst gun in the game you're playing
twitch geo you're playing twitch listen canadian
is old as [ __ ] but wait you're saying he's
only 24 and geo is actually older than him okay
weird flex then but still pretty hype taking the
number nine spot is a series of pop-offs from the
mad lions it just never stops with the mad lions
yeah i didn't pay for this mad lions have
quickly become one of the most exciting
teams on the rift most recently winning the 2021
lec spring playoffs but the organization has a
long history of hyping up the fans off the rift as
well in the webcam only era they came up with some
imaginative victory celebrations here with the
mad lions a little bit of a different style
they took a bit longer to come
online but once it got down
this looked incredible i love the
way they're able to play around
he's putting something on his he's got a
guitar the man has a guitar they've got an amp
it's hard to imagine any league of legends
team carrying musical equipment on stage
so in a way maybe this is a limited edition
pop-off we could only get in the online era
our number eight entry is the rare wholesome
pop-off see at summer jam 7 tekker player
pepper beef 2 spicy found himself facing
off against north america's champion
lil margin in pools the best of three
set went to literally the final round
and featured plenty of hype moments but at the
end pepper beef beat the people's champ and he
popped off with abandon in front of a stunned
hostile crowd before sheepishly shaking hands
oh my god oh and that will be that never
be too spicy knocks little margin to loses
but then after margin moved to exit the stage
it's like pepper beef realized he actually
needed to continue the pop off so he just
did his best impression of the leo win pose
this is an extremely underrated pop-off
that offers a true roller coaster of
emotion and lil margin was also a good
sport about it just an absolute classic
coming in at number seven is the pop-off that gave
any fans everywhere hope cloud niner in the grand
finals of esl one cologne 2017 and there we go
they've taken off their clothes at esl one cologne
2017 cloud9 made a deep run to semis we're a round
away from victory against navi and nothing came
in clutch at the right time and it's happening
nothing he does and he just stands up ice cold
but for it to happen that way for guardians then
after showing a dejected navi and their fans
the camera returned to nothing who had removed
his shirt and he didn't even put it back on
for the handshake line i think if anything it
might have been like oh i don't want to touch
you you get your shirt off like kind of funny but
those guys definitely like hate losing obviously
that the knob you guys just pure anime
protagonist energy from this pop-up
and number six pop-off is the direct result of a
truly impossible play with nothing but a p250 chad
i'm in disbelief clutches are difficult against
the world's best they're even harder when you're t
side 1b4 the bomb is covered and you have a
p250 but sometimes miracles happen and what
did he do after that that's nuts so he actually
shoots the author in the back of the head without
anyone looking that's the op and kills the guy
ct oh yeah ah yeah oh my god he's knifed him
and he's gotten away with the oil punch time to
get nervous there's no way there's no way katie
you can't win pro league like this you can't
win pro league like this no way exiles left 40
seconds and the bombs on a take your time son
you're about to make the play of your career
though he just has to hit this
shot and he's done it for heroic
the leader calling well above his years
clearing corners you're an animal heroic
have done it and i just can't believe it 40
of their team only together since february
and with nothing but a p250 chad i'm in disbelief
there's no roar of the crowd here this pop-off is
pure exhilaration from a team that
fought through the online era of cs
and were awarded for their hard work with one
of the best clutches in counter-strike history
at our halfway point is a pop-off from a man
known for his celebrations hungrybox yes oh my
oh my come come one calm yourself down juan
but sometimes calming yourself down just isn't an
option as the hype takes over and the only way you
can be stopped is actual physical injury at smash
and splash 3 hungrybox faced armada in winners
finals and after an extended bout he won and
pops off so hard he literally had to see a doctor
holy cat wait holy cow that was winter smiles
oh my god he's gonna break the tv to be honest
i understand why right now yeah i mean
he's like he was holding it okay dude
after the event hungrybox confirmed that he
went to a doctor and while there was no broken
bones he did have to wear a walking boot the best
part hungrybox still took the entire tournament
even with the injury and then he delivered an
impassioned speech what a beast we came here
from the gutter ourselves we can say whatever the
damn hell we want we have no help we ain't had
no we had no help from any person we came here
to ourselves and look at us we're still having
1500 people at a damn water park in wisconsin
who are we come on now at number four entry
is a pop-off so spicy that any young children
watching this might need to skip to the next entry
and you're gonna want to wash the
taste of my dick out of your mouth
the first of ten is an important
part of the fighting game community
and since they are sometimes used to settle a
score a pop-off is always a possibility and if
one happens it's likely to be personal when
biscan faced off against the controversial
low tier god at wednesday night fights
in 2014 things were pretty tense and
thankfully the tension gave us one of
the most iconic pop offs in history
why would we shake hands we do not shake
hands in crunch matches wow wow he has done it
all right look i got one more thing
to say i got one more thing to say
so there's going to come a point when you forget
about what happened and you're going to want to
come back at me and you're going to want to
wash the taste of my dick out of your mouth
coming in at number three is a desk destroying
pop-off from stewie2k it's team liquid and that's
what it means to them what's the next best thing
to winning a valve major in counter-strike well a
million dollar bonus for winning the intel grand
slam sounds pretty good to me esl one cologne
2019 was one of the most memorable moments in nacs
history as liquid did the impossible winning their
fourth esl or dreamhack event in a 10 event window
to win a cool million bucks it was na's greatest
triumph since winning the boston major and
stewie couldn't help but get a little bit excited
two versus two and liquid have the advances
they're trying to bring it down to the two
versus one if it's rpk this drop they could be
in serious trouble that should do it there we go
it's team liquid and that's what it means to them
they've taken it at the fourth map the favorites
coming into the tournament have just unlocked the
intel grand slam at esl one cologne underneath
our runner-up spot goes to the murder face
himself takedow taquito's akuma has always
been scary but the japanese fighting game phenom
took his psychological warfare to the next level
in 2010 at socal regionals a little explanation
here after akuma performs the iconic raging demon
super he turns away from the camera and the kanji
10 appears on his back which represents among
other things immortality it's a street fighter
staple anyway at scr 2010 taquito beat klekey d
but he wanted to rub it in just a little
so instead of shaking hands taquito walked
between the projector and screen in the venue
and mimicked akuma's raging demon victory poses
it's a legendary epic pop-off made all the cooler
because of taquito's signature character choice
but there's one pop-off that's just a little bit
better that's right and number one pop off is
k brad giving wolf crone a little bit of a
lecture about himself oh oh tell him tell
him about himself an incredible pop off has
so many pieces you've got the history between
the players the showmanship and the crowd's
reaction all factored in this pop-off has it all
k brad and wolfcrone had lots of prior history and
a recent loss meant k-brand was out for revenge
of final round 20. so after securing an
easy dub k brad made himself comfortable
and offered his rival some free advice
oh this is frank oh let me see this oh
everything about this pop-off is perfect it has
a history of disrespect the attitude and several
high-profile members of the fgc just giving us
their raw reactions well there we go guys that
was a pretty tough list to make there are so many
good pop-ups did we leave something out that we
really should have put on there let us know in the
comments section as always thanks for watching and
i'll see you all in the next one he's gonna have
to deuce i can't nope no more oh my god genius
so smart he couldn't burst because of the super
but will she get dicks it's over oh my god